this has just been at its best today
you can't yeah you can't get too upset
if you're playing the best player in the
world and they're on form
yeah he's he's showed real class today
isn't he and um you know he's never
really been in any danger and uh he he
might even finish by winning uh well
he's gonna win isn't he obviously here
yeah and there we go he's worked out the
checkmate as well finishing his style
yeah uh there's a checkmate on the e7
squad after uh a few moves uh this is
really nice once the black king takes
the white rook i hope prague is going to
let us see this there's a queen check
the white bishop is now going to give a
check the black king once it moves
okay it's checkmate next move
he doesn't allow it he doesn't allow it
now the check mate we want to see it but
what a performance by magnus what a
performance magnus carlsen wins this
match in three games and pragnanda
shakes his hand such a nice gesture by
the 16 year old who obviously is
disappointed
but yeah magnus carlsen watch a
performance pragnanda